hey guys do you want to be at your best
mentally all the time quick on your feet
having a good memory making better
decisions based on good
reasoning of course you do everybody
wants that
so how do you do it well you start by
giving your brain what it needs to
function
at its best so in this video i'm going
to show you the 10
best foods that'll boost your brain
power
let's get to it
[Music]
but mistakes make you strong and this is
very quick if it's the first time that
you're on my channel
welcome i'm daniel moritz and here i
talk about fitness grooming style and
life itself so if you haven't subscribed
yet please do
now let's start with the super brain
food
list coffee
this is by far my favorite why
because coffee has antioxidants and
caffeine both
are great for your brain it will not
only boost your alertness but also your
emotional mood it does so by stopping
adenosine
which is basically a chemical that makes
you sleepy
and it increases your serotonin making
you feel good
oh and coffee good coffee without sugar
also protects you against things like
alzheimer's and parkinson's disease
eggs who doesn't love eggs they're super
healthy
and they help you to build muscle but
that you also know
that they're actually great for your
brain power they contain folic acid
vitamin b6 and b12 which is super
important
for your brain to function better and
they also contain choline in the egg
yolks
which is important because it helps your
neurotransmitters to regulate your
memory
and your mood effectively
nuts and seeds they're not just good for
your heart
but also good for your brain they boost
it with healthy fats
vitamin e and other nutrients walnuts
may be the best because of their omega-3
fatty acids
dark chocolates you might think man this
can't be right because chocolate isn't
healthy
well dark chocolate contains a lot of
antioxidants flavonoids
this is contained in the cacao and
studies show that it can also improve
your memory
and your mood
[Music]
fatty and oily fish man i personally
love fish i even catch it myself when i
cook it
fatty fish like salmon trout mackerel
tuna and even sardines are
full of healthy omega-3 fatty acids
so why is it actually so good for your
brain
because 60 of your brain is fat
so your brain needs healthy fat to
function properly
especially to learn and memorize things
better
blueberries and other berries they're
probably a
better option than dark chocolate
because they're more healthier right
but berries also contain a good amount
of
flavonoids antioxidants and they are
really good for your brain power
strawberries blackberries mulberries
blackcurrants
are all good for you but blueberries are
my favorite
they're good because they help the
communication between your brain cells
and also protect you against
brain aging
whole grains they're awesome nothing
beats the taste and the smell of fresh
baked bread just out of the oven whole
grains may also improve your focus
and concentration by giving you low gi
energy
that means slow releasing energy for
your body
and your brain you don't have to stick
to bread you can choose different things
like brown rice
oatmeal barley pasta and then of course
whole grain bread now if you don't eat
enough
healthy carbs it might actually cause
brain fog
and also make you even more irritable
but
just try to stay away from gmo whole
grains because that might actually just
give you more
health problems
[Music]
broccoli now broccoli also contains
flavonoids antioxidants
and also vitamin k it slows down the
breakdown of acetylcholine
which is a neurotransmitter and you need
this to happen
so that your central nervous system
works smoothly and help your brain
to think and remember better other
vegetables like
kale cauliflower cabbage turnips pop joy
and brussels sprouts will also help you
to boost your brain
power pumpkin seeds
now i've already talked about the
benefits of nuts and seeds but
pumpkin seeds are special because
they're very
rich in micronutrients like iron zinc
magnesium
and copper and all of them are very
important for your brain
to function at its best pumpkin seeds
also improve
your mood with its magnesium b vitamins
and tryptophan
green tea by now you probably already
know just how healthy green tea is
for your body but just like coffee it's
also good
for your brain's performance because of
the caffeine
and also its antioxidants also protect
your brain from mental decline
and even from alzheimer's and
parkinson's disease
now remember you can't change your genes
right that's going to stay the same but
you can improve your body
and your brain by just eating the right
type
of foods you only have one body
in this life so take care of it
cheers guys